so the idea of this horrible sounding
movement of the intersectionalists is
that if you the whole of our society is
a set of interlocking oppressions and if
you unlock one of these oppressions you
unlock all of them it takes no account
of the fact that lots of these alleged
oppressions run completely against each
other
so for instance you see that the
slightly effeminate boy is actually a
girl
or you say that the Tomboy girl who
might grow up to be a lesbian or might
grow up to be heterosexual 80 of people
diagnosed with gender dysphoria turn out
not to have gender dysphoria but you do
this and you are running straight
against some very fundamental things of
the women's Liberation and women's
rights movement of recent decades you
are running very fundamentally against
the gay rights and Gay Liberation
movement recent decades and this is only
just being realized so what I say to the
intersectionalists is even on the basis
of your own Claim about Society works
you are creating a car crash